come together muslim made once again to
get to clean water families in gaza
105 pounds can provide interrupted water
to two families
for an entire year
well the korani app is about to show you
your progress with your soul yes that's
correct
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
yeah a couple times it talks about
inheritance
yes and i think there's a couple times
whereby
in certain situations a woman would get
less inheritance yeah do you think
i think it would make sense in
a community or a society where there's a
lot of muslims and they're part of the
same sort of
community they're together yeah and then
maybe it wouldn't make sense for a woman
to inherit as much because then when she
gets married she's then gonna
you know the man's gonna be the provider
in that situation but in a modern
society like let's say london let's say
there's a muslim family that's maybe
moved here
yeah maybe they're part of a community
where there's not as many muslims
and then the mom dies and you know she's
not somewhere where there's
a strong muslim community is
you know would that still be expected of
them for that they wouldn't get the
right inheritance away well they have to
because the thing is if you look at the
mata
people think the woman is in a
disadvantaged position yeah
that's not the case if you look at it
properly actually
it's we're happy with what allah has
legislated but from the outset
if you look at it look a woman she has a
carer
yeah provider allah says that men are
maintainers and providers of women
right so for example if there's a wall i
would go
if i'm walking down the road without the
next man puts a knife out i'm not gonna
say hey darling you go and sort this out
and call me when it's done of course
i'm gonna have to put my neck on the
line yeah yeah yeah yeah
i am the provider i have to work so for
example i'll give a situation
i pay the rent yeah i pay the shopping
okay i have to give my wife a certain
funds for her too you know i can say
okay i can afford i don't know i'm gonna
say
100 pound a week i'll give a sec yep
yeah i have to provide that
yeah so now if you look at it is this
really
um pro like i would say pro manual but
who's in an
advantage position on top of that
when i marry her she has a right to
maher dowry
so that diary can change from what's up
dowry
so that's her right so for example uh
when i one
marry my wife she has a right for a gift
and when i mean gift
she can ask for 10 grand she can ask for
20 grand
she can ask for gold she's gonna ask for
a five-star holiday
she can ask for a car she can ask for a
house but i can't afford it she's gonna
get married yeah
but the point is this that's her right
so she has that right to ask now the
money let's suppose um
let's suppose somebody's wife the wife
to be
says i want five thousand pounds and i
want to go on a trip to honolulu
yeah if that's agreed he has to provide
that
right yeah on top of that he has to do
the wedding the nikya
ceremony and he has to do lima which is
a wedding of announcing the marriage
yeah yeah so there's nothing hidden
going on yeah yeah
and bear in mind i talked about working
if somebody comes with a knife
yeah yeah okay mine's a full-time body
card imagine that yeah yeah and then
the money that i give her i can't touch
a penny that's hers
okay so if i'm broke crying at home
yeah she can be spending money not on me
on shopping no no i know but the point
is this islam gives her the right
that she that's her money i can't touch
it and the question here is how comes a
woman gets less
now in this instance let's put it in the
perspective i paid for the wedding
yeah i do the the wedding ceremony yeah
i have to provide for her i have to show
to her yeah
when there's a danger i'm there yeah the
money i give her
she keeps it yeah on top of that when
inheritance happens let's say her father
dies she gets
for example half of that of a man yeah
yeah right
okay this is a bit confusing okay now
check this out
she didn't pay for nothing she's been
uh catered for yeah i gave her that five
grand remember
she keeps that from her dad her dad uh
had a hundred grand
yeah um the daughter will get um
i think it's 33 grand or something
around this line yeah and he will get
76. something along those lines for what
i remember yeah i think it's one
uh something i can't remember i i forgot
yeah she will keep that the son
the money that he gets he has to what do
what
if his daughter gets married for example
there's certain things that he has to do
and the groom okay she keeps the money
the
the son has to provide for the mom if
the doctor in the picture
his daughters yeah his wife so if the
wife's dad dies then her husband gets
more money
no no no if the the girl imagine my
wife's father
you've got to give them wrong like
imagine passed away yeah and imagine my
wife had a
brother yeah the brother will get more
than nothing but bear in mind the money
that she gets she keeps
yeah and he has to he is looking after
his mom and his wife
his daughters so the money that he gets
is just fair because
he's going to be spending it on his wife
which is another woman and his daughter
there's another woman
and his mother which is another woman so
is it expected for a woman to marry
somebody of islamic faith yes she has to
she's not allowed to marry nonsense
okay yeah yeah yeah so so if you look at
it
she's in a better position because she
doesn't spend and anything she gets she
keeps
but the man is a provider so her brother
might get a lot but he's
spending a lot yeah so in that sense and
not only that
if you look at islamic finance for
example we studied this
in 16 15 16 cases a woman
we're just looking at the brother and
sister center yeah a woman gets
more money in inheritance than 16 or 15
uh male family members right so the
uncle the paternal uncle
the cousins so she gets more inheritance
than 14 male family members okay in that
instance
so people don't talk about that so when
you look at things you know and
in detail you will see that the woman is
in a better opposition
yeah and the man is in a position where
he's providing and looking after when
he's yeah
you know okay what do you think um
[Music]
if you have any questions you can ask as
well any questions
[Music]
a woman grows up wanting to be a
provider
oh yeah she can not wanting the choice
of having everything given to her
because i know there's loads of people
yeah like this the fact that
everything's given to you she loves to
pay rent you know what
really mohammed he just sent me an
article yesterday uh off it's about
feminism
and they did a study over 20 years
and they found out they interviewed i
think 100 000 females
in the workplace and 17 to 80
or more were unhappy working they
preferred to be
at home and there's a book by not will
what's her name
he wrote a book uh the delusion of men's
uh
meant men's power something along those
lines and you should read it
but yeah yeah yeah you're saying here so
if she choose to work
she can yes she can work potentially
that means you've got more money yeah
the husband the husband can't touch that
money
okay i'm right okay yeah
where i'm at in the quran or maybe a
little bit before where i'm at there's a
bit where it says that
something like god takes us by night and
then returned to us
yeah sort of the day for a specified
term or whatever do you think that
when you're sleeping do you think you're
sort of uh
you don't remember what happens when you
sleep really do you think there's some
sort of
connection with god happening there yeah
we believe